بالفعل حدث هذا قبل 40 دقيقه تقريبا كانت
قد بدات التظاهره عند الساعه الحاديه عشره
بتوقيت بيروت ولكن تقريبا بعد ساعه واكثر
من ساعه ونصف تقريبا حاول المحتجون اقتحام
ليس بالفعل السري ولكن الشارع موازي
للسرايا الحكومي لكن الرد من قبل القوى
الامنيه كان رد شديد بعض الشيء كان هناك
اطلاق لعدد كبير من القنابل المسيله
للدموع علما ان مئات كان هناك مئات
المحتاجين الذين توافدوا منذ الصباح ولكن
علما ان معظمهم كان كبير بالسن خاصه وان
معظم المجموعات هي مجموعات لمتقاعدين من
الجيش اللبناني والقوى الامن الداخلي
والجمارك لذلك كان استخدام كان هناك
استخدام مفرطي القوه وكان هناك حالات
اغماء بين صفوف المتظاهرين
هذه الحاله لم تدم لدقائق طويله كان هناك
كثافه بالقاء القنابل المسيله بعدها تراجع
المحتجون الى الخلف وقل عدد المشاركين كل
عدد المشاركين في التظاهره التي كان هناك
دعوه اليها يوم امس مع ارتفاع سعر الصرف
مع الغلاء المعيشي مع يعني تهديد اصحاب
محطات الوقود بالاغلاق وايضا وايضا
الصيدليات تمت هذه الدعوه من قبل كما ذكرت
متقاعدين ايضا بعض مجموعات حراك السابع
عشر من تشرين وبعض وبعض النواب التغيرين
ماذا عن اعداد المحتجين المتواجدين الان
في الساحه ايضا غنوه
وهل تجد الدعوات ايضا التي جاءت على اكثر
من ربما نائب في وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
هل تجد صدى في زياده اعداد المتظاهرين
توجههم الى
مساحه رياض الصلح تحديدا يعني
اللفت خالد انه لدى التوجه توجه بعض
النواب الى هذه الساحه كان هناك رفض من
قبل المتظاهرين بان يبقى النواب هنا طلبوا
منهم مغادره مغادره الساحر بالرغم من ان
هؤلاء النواب يعتبرون انهم من صف
المواطنين وبانهم طالبوا بان تتحول اللجان
الانيبيع التي عاده تنعقد لمناقشه امور
حياتيه
يعني طالب بتحويل هذه اللجان الى لجان
مسائله للحكومه خاصه وان الحكومه لم تتخذ
حتى هذا اليوم اي اجراء اصلاحي من اجل
تخفيف حده الازمه الاقتصاديه ولكن
المتواجدين هنا في الساحه طلبوا النواب
بالمغادره لانهم يعتبرونهم ربما جزء من
السلطه بغض النظر عن موقفهم موقفهم
المعارض
المتواجدون هنا يعتبرون انهم يعني يقبضون
رواتب تقاعديه كانوا قد ادخروها على مدى
اعوام من عملهم على سعر صرف اليوم بعض
الرواتب لا تتعدى العشرين دولار